I live most of my life out on YouTube
with only a little channel handful of
subscribers mmm
I reckon they didn't like me on the
platform long bit back then it was
mostly just me uploading short videos
and me talking to my camera hmm ain't
had nothing but a bed see the camera
come for the microphones down there well
back then the Young Turks used to make
like a better sport of me they teased me
quite a bit I got to the point where I
could feed hopper cheese and biscuits
four times a week but mostly I just sat
out there making videos on my channel
well one night I was doing much nothing
just tearing that to youtube mm-hmm
searching on a preggers u video for the
Electoral College all I could find was a
nerd trying to make up tutorials and my
suggested food so I logged into my
YouTube account to see what was wrong
with it
turned out that was video didn't put in
restricted
I haven't been unsubscribed from the
ladder was crowded my favorite channel
mmm I had to reach subscribe quite a bit
but even when I did I didn't receive no
notifications and had to hit the bell
three times
mm-hmm but then I ain't see nothing but
Trevor nobody owes my suggested feed
then I just seen reading I hired myself
a higher facing lawyer some people think
he's a Mexican he's higher face mmm-hmm
got Holman little shake ties and here to
stick out straight I decide of his here
don't matter how he could it I reckon
you just buff out like that Dyke his
pitching because he's out of fun and
whatnot
hmm but I had my little build area go on
in that talk with YouTube with top
lawyers and partly with theme about our
question don't my channel but they
didn't answer nowhere to not the
restrictions he monetization
they just kept asking that to spend more
money on advertising and screaming
what'd you do [ __ ] bang for what you
do [ __ ] Bane fur mmm
I reckon that made me madder than the
whole notification business I had bill
Richman he's out fighting some people
think he's half Mexican he's half asian
I had him walk right on into Sue's
muddies Keys office at YouTube sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mother-in-law to wedding sorry dad I see
it is that's it not only father's but
uncles and grant let's take at a wedding
there's some don't trust the uncles to
do that do not trust the uncles it's
alcohol you don't know it's not it no
it's not
I have teetotaling relatives huh for me
it's the alcohol open bars as well for
you it's always the alcohol all right we
have great guests today we have Nicole
Arbour on boom we have Dinesh D'Souza on
she's pretty we were going have already
lying on but uh well it didn't work out
we have them on we love art we're gonna
have them on next week obviously this
comes as no surprise
so that'll that'll probably be a
pre-taped and this this was a pre tape
with Nicole Arbour because of boobs
butts sling my what because a sling mud
club all right listen before we move on
first up question of the day have you
found that debate because we'll be
getting into this a clip from the rebel
which i think is emblematic of how the
left debates have you found that
debating with progressives has become
easier and easier thanks to the talking
points now becoming so predictable and a
follow up put a percentage on it I'd
like to hear from you we often hear
about the radical left and finding the
center what percentage of today's
Democrats would you put under sort of
the classical JFK liberal versus
perpetual victim complex progressive
today give a percentage point let me
know because I think they're a
significant majority and when you're a
majority you're no longer radical fringe
as it relates to the progressive wing
all right producer these main videos to
do as always this charity was not a fun
Twitter not could you describe the
comments your thoughts your photoshop's
I fulfill my obligations are you good
I'm good I appreciate it and we have at
G Morgan Jr the creator look at that
picture
okay the creator of Marley R so what is
that looks like the singer from corn
maybe at Brody now Brautigan is it is
filling in here temporarily you are my
first hire actually a lot are with
CARICOM yes I have seniority
how long have so how long we work
together gods I think we said since 87
about five years yes six years yeah and
people you can send him out your stories
at Brautigan he's often the one who gets
us stories going in the morning any
happened to be in town also Cockburn is
something he said I don't like that lead
in one bit I just got out of the clink
to escape the Cockburn University
researchers have barely run out of
things to research a new study suggests
that people are racist against black
household robots what comes from
spectrum Wally I guess as a website the
findings of a new study suggests that
people perceive robots with
anthropomorphic features to have race
and as a result of the same race related
prejudices is a prejudice robots well
you know what maybe if they weren't so
lippy let's say my Google Home has a
race but it refuses to play any other
Jimmy Buffett that's it there how many
times I ask for killer Mike it's a race
if it's just Margaritaville on an aloof
the race is college dropout and yeah you
know point about this product up and
kill us one day yeah yeah the t2 thing
for you right there it is I don't if
action listen that was my favorite
movies a kid don't turning our attention
to Hollywood Ryan Reynolds attached to a
revision of the film home alone this was
called stoned alone sending around you
guessed at a pothead though actually it
seems the title might need to be renamed
as to not confuse it with the Saudi
Arabian holiday called classic
wearing a woman drove by herself there
is at least a cross between baby driver
and not without my daughter and and
stoning of sir I am yes all about it's
fun for the whole family such an
advanced culture so the film centers
around a twenty-something weed-growing
loser who misses the plane for his
holiday ski trip first answer the
casting call was macaulay culkin because
he does that thanks there's look at look
at there's no way michael jackson did
not have something no no you got a piece
he touched him in a way that he will
never ever since home alone i've been
preparing for this role
ready yeah bring me back ever since home
alone one he's been pretty was locked
into the home alone yeah remember brock
turner is anyone here cuz because i
didnt does everyone remember yeah
remember um convicted of sexual assault
for those don't know his lawyer is now
claiming that he only engaged in quote
outercourse
not intercourse what is the point of
that
well okay people this is how it's
described from People magazine the
lawyer defined outercourse as sexual
activity while clothes that can be
considered a form of safe sex way to put
a spin on it the Turner quote didn't
intend to rape the victim which to be
fair I guess we're doing the definition
of is but it isn't as bad as intercourse
which of course is sex between galaxies
and then Christopher Nolan and secured
the rights to in Sept the course which
is sex within a sex within a [ __ ]
walls go like this and there's rape
somewhere also known as also is a
casting call with Harvey Weinstein yes I
mean obviously you're talking about rape
so I'm not making fun of that but that's
like the dumbest thing I've ever heard
outercourse what kind of balls do you
have to have to claim that it's your
defense apparently it doesn't matter
because you're wearing jeans anyway so
it's it's irrelevant I cannot believe it
this is a transcript imagine going for
imagine going forward in a court and
Blake no no no your honor
it was out of course debt is where my
client was merely dry humping her leg
against her will simple battery like if
you were to create a sleazy lawyer who's
who will say anything
you would create this yeah this is what
he'd say yes it's attorney outercourse
does it hold water I don't know what all
I did was hump a leg the question is
like the three months that Brock was in
prison
how much out of course did he get yeah
let's see if he splits the definition
early that's Shawshank core so in a
related story a man who has no penis
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
another quote one of the women believed
she was being penetrated by his penis
[Laughter]
when it comes to the work on the force
[ __ ] burns no joke detective we now have
two cases in two weeks of women being
sexually accosted sir all right
better just send the son down the
Special Victims Unit there's only one
problem sir
it's the assailant he didn't have a oh
my god that means there's only one
choice we need to bring in the Cockburn
sir with all due respect coppers too
close to this sir cappers had enough
yeah but I'll tell you in Cockburn's had
enough you may not like Cockburn you may
not like the methods you may not even
like the fact that Cockburn will push
you to your limits just to find out what
they are but my god there's no one
better for this case than Cockburn
and the only reason you're still
standing here is because you know and
you son of a [ __ ] sir I don't think
it's a good idea not since oh I know
about Oakland don't you think I know
about that but sir Cochran's wife was
killed by this man come over here deputy
if you want to have a job in my precinct
you keep your [ __ ] mouth shut about
Oakland he'll be selling cigarettes out
of a bodega on 8th and wacker between
paying a hobos playtoy so fast it'll
make your head spin do you hear me I
wouldn't call on Cockburn unless
absolutely necessary my god when you're
out there with inkless monsters roaming
these streets with no end in sight and
you need the best damn person for this
hyper specific niche Millia you thank
the sweet lord jesus that someone exists
out there like Cockburn yes commissioner
get Cockburn silver dollar
we have no choice all right you can't
make these things we have to get well no
we did we did we got a real show it's
not a real film in case you didn't know
no can you imagine him going and buying
set and inanimate objects at the adult
stores and it's like give me something
that won't raise any eyebrows or it's
not clear the stories might clarify but
those objects well what do you think it
was room it could be a plastic sword the
point is with this honestly usually if
someone is sexually costing someone he
is meeting in between you know needing
oxygen if you read this story the guy
had a very well-thought-out plan to hide
the fact that the light toys always had
to be off no one could look him in the
eye
she's like here how about this one no
that I just it's a very very bizarre
crime I'm going to safety deposit box
and give them all my coins
oh my guess it's got to be the dumbest
thing that bird always gets her man you
hear partner badge heads will never get
this real story you'll never see two gay
guys trying to pull this off I mean you
really I don't think it would work the
same yeah I don't know I guess Patrick
Stewart is not gay what a lot of people
thought he was gay with yeah I thought
he was gay he was like he still does not
convinced by hammock Ian McKellen yeah
which is funny because II McKellen seems
way less gay yeah you know very if they
were to say actually whatever for
example you know it would take for them
becoming an actual gay couple just
Patrick Stewart saying yes yeah yeah
every man
they're Hollywood's hottest couple
people get mad it's like what do you
think yeah I'm saying that men are just
so animalistic and their sexual urges
you remove one part of that equation
which is a curtain yeah yeah just yeah
gay people it's just a party of yes as
opposed to lesbian couples where it's a
party of I have a headache exactly and
that goes exactly aspirin may get the
cockscomb happy sensitive I think that
goes against like for some reasoning
guys heads we think of guys and guys and
we're like ah that's it's incredibly
gross right yes and then for some reason
the general public not me
when you think about two girls are like
it seems plausible it's too hot and
that's actually the opposite of what
happens doesn't you know that's one
thing obviously to me is oh it's just
never Mattox a people like they're like
four boobs four boobs are better than
two that's with an explanation just men
like seen breasts yes come on
sorry Madison we have a girl who works
with us now in the awareness and you
know I'm pretty sure we didn't let the
cat out of the bag all right move on to
this this comes to us from the rebel I
highly recommend that you go watch the
entire clip before that by the way hit
our notification bail because
subscriptions don't mean anything
anymore
and join my club you get this full hour
show every single day lot of clutter
calm slash mug Club in live streams if
you don't you can live some every
Thursday here on YouTube at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern anyway so this comes from the
rebel please go watch the whole video
for context I just thought it was very
good it was perfect to crystallize the
techniques the tactics I left use right
now when it comes to debating and mainly
there are five and you've heard us talk
about them but we wanted to take a video
and give you a play-by-play just in case
there were any doubt so let's go to the
first but were right away this person by
the way this is after the term to set
the context after the toronto shooting
yeah not a lot of news about this for
people who don't know it was a big
shooting I think 16 people were shot
finally wow how do you know how many
people died did it I'm not sure what
lest I heard - last I heard - okay
that's why I'd hurt - because you never
know obviously some tragedies happen but
right after that one reporter for the
rebel went and spoke about obviously the
Muslim ties so right away this lady
freaks out and goes to progressive
tactic number one before the clip the
number one technique they uses
of course accuse racism she and she just
got a clip can you please not descend
into racist things right now please what
I'm sorry what did I say that was racist
sorry this is not what Canada is about
Canada is not about racism the rebel is
a racist source of news okay I love the
fact that she started with like still on
the phone with a friend yes like I have
to pull you back I gotta go on the phone
with her friend while she has kids there
with objects that could be easily
swallowed like I'm sorry I actually I'm
actually I'm doing pseudo cool my child
please the plastic bag over his head I
think so in record time too by the way
the racism and then we know this I don't
really even need to go over as a whole
but it's a tool that's used to actually
bring you into their their number two
technique which we'll get to in a second
but first here's what's important why
did she accuse this reporter again go
watch the whole video at the rebel it's
up here on YouTube or I think rebel dot
media why'd she accuse him of being
racist here's exactly why I say anything
that was racist shooter had visited Isis
websites that is not I said CBS in the
US I said CBS in the u.s. is reporting
that okay alright and the truth is the
day that this video was being filmed CBS
was reporting that the shooter was but
by the way the Muslim shooter had
expressed interest in Isis yes
by the way Isis even took credit for it
so it doesn't sound like they were too
far off base no at least potentially
right no you never know you can't always
go by what Isis takes credit for no no
that's definitely true if anyone kills
anybody Isis like is it all count over
to yeah we know what really pisses me
off about this is if you watch it from
the beginning he's very like politely
asking questions he asked a separate
question about motive and then said hey
here's what's being reported what do you
think and this lady who is absolutely
not a part of the conversation leans in
still on the cell phone oh they're
talking about some racist stuff hold on
I gotta chime in because people think my
opinions valued yeah exactly
so she's she's a horrible human being
and this brings us to the method number
two I was talking about the next thing
that she does and we see this one okay
so let's just tell you how you have no
right to speak they just try to deny
your right to speak completely we see
her do that multiple times throughout
the video don't come here
the rebel really you need you don't need
to be here right now and this you are
not my community you can leave now you
so cold medias need to not be here based
on based on whose authority you have no
business being here with your racist
crap get your racist crap out of my
community get it out now
was that the Somali pirate from Kevin
Brown a few pounds looking for a 15
gonna be in there not the hero this
Toronto needs your Toronto belongs to me
report is gone I am the captain where I
am the dark night now where's his crack
by the way this is just not necessarily
appointment just for complete bonus
stupidity and insanity this is the kind
of argument that only the insane
rant about the rebel is a racist source
of news because we're asking people
their opinion of mass shooting and the
match what is the mass shooting have to
do with a man that busily come on
come on man have to do with a man who
you didn't finish that sentence that
sentence because the sentence makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever you put
words together to make a phrase that
confuses people who are not [ __ ]
it's like flip microwave toaster bagel
wait wait why that why should I have to
explain have to tell you cuz I want to
know if I need to call the EMTs if you
have a stroke racist so this brings us
example it's just to let they don't want
to deal in reality and I don't know if
she even believes what she's saying or
if she's just that stupid or if she's so
dogmatic but she doesn't realize she's
that stupid it's like the stupid liberal
chicken and egg but the chicken is at
the egg she's just following chicken
liberal Toronto mayor who instead by the
way use this exact same tragedy to
immediately pivot to gun control you've
heard me ask the question of why anybody
would need to buy 10 or 20 guns which
they can lawfully do under the present
laws and that leads to another question
we need to discuss why does anyone in
this city need to have a gun at all I
know you've been answering that
won't fully eliminate tragedies like
this but even if we can prevent one of
these incidents then in my view it is a
Scott a discussion worth having that's
first up I love now it's the number of
guns yeah no you should be compact the
amount of bullets in the gun
yeah the amount of rounds in the
magazine or watch it's almost like you
realized that didn't help
yeah why would anyone need for
single-shot shotguns walk around like a
rock I mean the fact that there's a guy
who may or may not be Isis because we
don't know right right you need four
guns in case the first three miss yes
exactly and then it's one two pistol
buttom for good measure as well he's out
now this is the kind of derangement and
I do mean derangement that leads to
tweets like this from Toronto novelist
and I think vice writer who wanted to
put a man quote on white men just cuz
he's looking for a reason to be crazy
and the crew this was before they found
out he was a Muslim right yeah it was
let's put a ban on white man till we
figure this out because it's Canada so
they assume it's a white male but to be
fair that's a roll of the dice yes okay
you're sure you're lucky lucky blow on
that you're probably rolling up snake
guys but yeah because historically
that's what white men tend to do we tend
to join Isis and go blow things up in
the name of Allah right that makes
perfect sense to me real quick I want to
go back to one thing that he said he's
like if we can even prevent one yeah
exactly
if we can prevent one of these it's a
converse no it's not no that's the
stupidest really lazy
did you think freedom was going to end
yeah I know you don't quite have the
same kind of freedom obviously not even
close in Canada but for here it's messy
I'm sorry if we get even to prevent with
one death by banning every single
private pool would you not do it
especially here about don't we can
prevent one for his fire if we can
prevent one robber from dying in your
kiddie pool in the videos if we could
prevent one transgender suicide not the
41 percent attempts just the one percent
by telling them that they're actually a
man my God my God why wouldn't you do it
[Laughter]
but my here's the technique they use in
the next
using the mob mentality we've talked
about this the Left uses quite a bit the
power of the audience to try and
intimidate you again into silence if
they haven't just denied your right to
speak you can't speak you know what now
we're gonna bring in other people
hopefully intimidate you into not
speaking so right here it's bringing the
reinforcements community us doesn't know
anything about this community so this
this this is Danforth this is our city
this our city we here's the thing well I
need to not be here based on based on
whose authority based on my authority
cuz I live here do you okay it's like
she hadn't even thought about the what
what can you get deputies in Toronto
just by living there yes look I love
this guy in the background like he's
like this is my moment and he walks up
he's fumbling through his words it he
goes back to her he's like he's grabbing
the mic to have a black man you found us
I'm black to potential and we people
talk about enlisting the white knight in
this case Black Knight it's just great
it's just a coming right in and it's a
is like listen and this is so funny to
me too this is our story this is not
America story oh really
so there was nothing about Demi Lovato
and Canadian news all of your stories
are American stories nationally you do
something so screwed up but you make it
a national news it doesn't mean that we
don't get to cover it dummy that's like
it's like Captain Phillips pirate didn't
think it through
alright by the way here's just some
crazy bonus footage again because we
figured we had to include it you prefer
a communist society
I prefer socialist society yes I do it
in Venezuela perhaps North Korea Cuba
I'm naming all that I'm naming all the
social sending into your own hell right
now listen these are hell holes I agree
with you holes now you're quoting Trump
lovely he did a different kind of haul
quoting holding Trump is the best thing
you could have ever done for yourself
way to go that was priceless
way to go I'm done here if you say so
have to be done you quote a trump
therefore you're done here because I
said the Trump was racist and you are
and now you're a racist quoted another
racist
it's like Inceptor racist which brings
us to their top number four technique we
all know this playing victim so we say
okay you're a racist you have no right
to speak let's bring in the mob to
intimidate you and at this point if
you're still speaking what they do even
if they have the mob is they play the
victim they act as though you are
attacking them because if they are a
victim they therefore have the moral
high ground you see your do this plays
out to the to to the letter just asking
questions but you're yelling at your a
question nor is it appropriate are you
really a schoolteacher yes I am is this
how you teach your children by the way
it's pretty met them no come on man
seriously seriously sirs are you that
dense dude I've never seen you teach man
seriously are you seriously that dense
I mean you said you're a teacher don't
question my profession does that matter
just wondering where you identify myself
to you I don't have to justify I have to
justify my yelling cussing racist
accusations at you sir it's my it's my
First Amendment right which I don't
believe in and doesn't exist in our
country's constitution she actually goes
on to talk about her right though she
says I know my Amendment rights did you
forget I'm not what we call them here
yeah I know right
two American News confusing your rights
again right here if you were to say I
know my Amendment rights to a police
just on a routine stop they'd say all
right let's put you in the breathalyzer
you know I know my First Amendment
rights I know my second of hemorrhoids
cuz I know my Amendment rights you don't
you don't have them cuz it's a crappy
country
we'll just and this brings us to a
number for their favorite tech not their
favorite but one of them it's the appeal
to authority fallacy this is what they
do a lot the left so to recap they go
racism deny your right to speak mom
mentality then play the victim and then
if that doesn't work they just really
want you to shut up
they either present someone else who
knows more like centers consensus from
scientists who cannot be here right now
or no yes or exact order here look at
this degree therefore I'm a so what's
the name of the socialist I forget her
name something something Cortez
something something coordination like I
have degree in economics so I know
economic
well why don't you answer the question
economics I have a degree it's magic and
she does it right here know anything
about social reform do not know anything
about representative governments I have
two degrees in political science man
don't even try to challenge me please
educate me don't even try that's like a
female gonna come at me bro
let's go here's my question - at this
point what happened to her son like did
he just a walking home he's at a tattoo
parlor somewhere watch the clip the kid
is clearly embarrassed it's like that
was hilarious to me with the kids like
Oh mom can we leave and she's like
weirdo we're staying here we're
supporting this and we're getting ice
cream aside of pretend rights yes in my
country but here with all this is what's
even more scary this is kind of that you
know these are the implementations of
the rage fully insane it wouldn't be
such a big deal if was just this crazy
tiny minority of people relegated to
insane asylums being dipped in
electrical shock water like shutter
island' if that were like okay there are
a few people out there instead and this
is what we've been talking that's what I
want to know what you think the
percentages of radical left-wing is what
they make up of today's progressive wing
versus the moderates because this person
is you guessed it teaching your children
what do you do for a living right now
man I'm a high school teacher yeah okay
about people like you and about your
agendas and about the racist crap that
you guys propagate in my city after a
tragedy look at that there it is it's
her face one yeah yeah I teach three
that's the face of yeah I get your kids
for seven hours a day and I get to
force-feed them my bull crap saying that
you're racist and that capitalism is
wrong and that soda and guess what
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
yeah that's cockiness about her
propaganda and indoctrination and really
child abuse at that point and this is
something that Americans really need to
understand why is she so emboldened to
say this why can she swear cuss make
personal attacks and then threatened to
call the cops call the cops on the
reporter by the way with no fear of
ramifications on her part here's why
you're gonna call the police completely
inaccurate and irrelevant this is
illegal under Canadian law and you know
what unfortunately not but if you start
spewing racist crap that is hate speech
yes it is ah there it is when people say
why Aloha when I did
change mine we did the change behind
hate speech isn't real people said well
you shouldn't say mean things but that's
right this man wasn't saying mean things
he asked question using hate CBS is
reporting that Isis hate speech I'm
gonna call the cops there it is that's
what I and Jordan Peterson and my people
like mike Ward have been funny against
for a long time the people who write use
respect and manipulate hate speech laws
are the person you see right there okay
this is what's important oh she's just
great this is one who's like the radical
left and out okay she's just great she's
just the radical left she's just this
fringe how far is she off from Melissa
clique remember the college professor I
need some muscle here
she was so comfortable doing that or or
the entire human troop into Tribunal's
with mattress girl in UVA and the radio
candles her men never had any recourse
the entire no one at the colleges said
anything think about that for a second
she's a high school teacher how far off
do you think she is from most high
school teachers from most college
professors let me ask you this how far
off do you think she is from Nancy
Pelosi how far off do you think her da
ideology is from Hillary Clinton picture
this woman in office you know why
because we already have them and they
want to be in control as you hear of
what you can say the only reason the
United States is is what what we are and
they are not is because of the first
amendment which is what they want to do
away with in Canada they don't have it
at all and she even vocalizes she's
facing I'm involved I'm involved in the
state because I say it's hate speech and
it's illegal she just uses that as part
blush to accuse the man for saying what
about this man who made had some
involvement Isis she thinks that she can
verbally berate harass somebody and
she'll get away with it you know why
because she can call the cops and have
this guy arrested for asking a question
and you know what in Canada and in the
kind of United States that Hillary
Clinton Nancy Pelosi the Young Turks
everyone would have if given their
choice that man could be arrested that
should send shivers down your spine call
in Cockburn you know Cockburn to fix us
we have Dinesh D'Souza after this break
[Music]
and now for hopper proverbs sponsored
exclusively by mug Club
it is said a squirrel does not run
because it has somewhere to be a
squirrel run because he's a dick
just like Confucius the job of your both
dicks join my class stay tuned for more
hopper proverbs sponsored by mug club
[Music]
what this says but I realized what I
kind of think this I've been watching
River Monsters hmm and when he strapped
in and doing the the fishing this he
does it kind of like he goes on an angle
I've never really fished very much but I
just used to fetch it and you reel it in
apparently have to give it some line
it's a hole that's why people are in
delay you're just pre scrubbing your
dishes before you put them in the
dishwasher to have it do the rest would
make sense
that's what else it also makes you a
Mendes fighter does you will win the
valley karate tournament if you wash it
enough dishes all right next guess huge
huge name obviously in the conservative
went in the home side he's had some
movies some of the biggest documentaries
of all time we've had him on the show
before you can follow him on the Twitter
at the Nash D'Souza that kind of suppose
you know who it is his latest the death
of a nation premieres August 3rd mr.
D'Souza how are you sir great to be on
the show I'm gone I'm glad to have you
on the show now you're looking you're
looking tan which you know I know is a
weird thing because you're you're a
minority but you're looking more tan
than last time we saw you even getting
some Sun I think it's because I did a
family trip to Hawaii
and I you know every now and then I have
to reinforce the natural tan and so plus
this also preserves my ethnic
credibility yes
I sometimes preface my statement with as
a person of color yes I can I really
work if I'm not a person of color yeah
well you're really a person of a shade
more so but it's funny because that's we
were just talking about that I think
yesterday the n-double-a-cp
you couldn't say color people it became
racist for so long but they just never
admitted it and now they're kind of
right back into it they just reversed it
to people of color but that includes
everyone yourself included so it's not
very accurate this is true well you know
um I think what it is is that the
Democratic Party these days now the
pratik party used to be the party of the
working class right and the Republican
Party was the party of the business
class but now the Democratic Party has
reorganized and it's essentially I
believe it's the party of the ethnic
plantation now of course originally
Steven the party of the slave plantation
but today that plantation is gone
multiracial young so they've got not
just the black ghettos they've got
Latino Barrios they've got the Native
American reservations so they don't like
to campaign for votes individually they
just want to collect each ethnic group
deposit you on a plantation create a
kind of intergenerational dependency in
which you trade your vote in exchange
for a kind of meager provision and then
you're permanently in thrall to the
Democratic Party
yeah well it's rocket if you can make it
work it is a good record especially if
you have the bus isn't he give him free
sandwiches and you take them to the
voting booth where the option is
Democrat or Democrat and heroin you know
you put just put that on the ticket and
make an opinion that there's genius the
genius of this plantation system is that
it gets people to vote Democratic
regardless of who is on the ticket right
this is true let me ask you this have
you do you have you ever referred to
yourself or does anyone ever refer to
you as asian-american being Indian
because I was wondering about that well
of course all these categories are kind
of bogus I mean when you think for
example I mean my wife's Venezuelan
right so she falls into the Latino camp
but that camp includes Cubans it
includes Mexicans
similarly the Asian category is very
light I mean obviously Indians and
Chinese don't have a whole lot in common
ethnically or even historically right
but we got thrown into the same barrel
and to me the puzzle about it isn't the
ethnic label it's it's why Asian
Americans aren't voting in ratios of 80
to 90 percent for the Republican Party
as a group asian-americans are their
meritocratic they're entrepreneurial
they are socially to the right of Pat
Robertson and yet we're reasons unknown
they are still in the Democratic camp
I don't know how agents are thought to
be smart but this is one area three
careful they're still very smart they're
just misled on that but I always
wondered because people oriental we've
always said this is a much more accurate
term because a lot of people they would
not say oh yeah that's just don't if I
were describing you to someone who
didn't know you
yeah he's this he's this guy who's
written a lot of books and he's that
asian-american guy that's not only white
feminist or even offended by it at all
they used it all the time you go down in
Chinatown oriental or it's on every
building you said asian-american that go
behind the
Indian gentleman international tell us
about your latest film now you've you've
done quite a few that have been really
big and this one is death of a nation we
have some footage rolling here what's it
about what can people expect well the
the poster is a little bit provocative
we morph the heads of Trump and Lincoln
and of course the never Trump person to
think it's that Trump is a is a steep
falling off from Reagan I think you're
going to have a constipation attack here
because you know how dare you compare
Trump to Lincoln but interestingly the
situation's of the two guys are not that
dissimilar I mean let's think about all
this political craziness we've been
seeing since the election is about a
major political party the Democrats yeah
refusing to accept the result of a
lawful election an outside guy comes in
challenges for the Republican ticket
knocks out the favorites and then beats
the Democrat well that happened in 1860
and so in 1860 the Democrats also went
nuts then they broke up the country this
time they're merely trying to stage a
kind of coup so the movie it's a deep
dive into two big issues fascism and
racism or white supremacy and as you
know these are the two incendiary tails
that the left is trying to hang on the
Republican elephant and so the movie
questions this challenges it takes you
to Europe takes you into Mussolini dives
into there not just the history of the
Democratic Party but where is the racism
now yeah it's it's eye-opening and it's
it's gonna blow people away so I'm very
excited I haven't seen it yet I haven't
seen this yet but we've talked about
Mussolini on the show quite a bit in
your movie is he a rather pathetic
character because he uh whenever I think
of Mussolini you know Hitler terrible
person obviously Stalin terrible person
Mussolini also a terrible sad Hitler's
yeah but he's but it also makes me very
sad because he was kind of pathetic well
he was a very strange guy I mean if you
look at video of Mussolini online it
almost seems cartoonish he you know be
the Italians kind of from the Mafia
movies
well Mussolini is that in italics choice
remind you of Goldfinger yes Goldfinger
his exaggerated mannerisms and so on now
interestingly in his own time Mussolini
was seen as a serious guy he was very
very well-read in sort of Marxist
literature and history
he wrote extensive I mean scholarly or
at least semi scholarly articles and
that says he compares very favourably
with Hitler and of course he was a man
at the left he was an acquaintance of
lemon lemon sent him a telegram
congratulating him when he started the
the fascist party yeah in Italy and so
the fact that Hitler and Mussolini came
from the left
well he's well-read but what I mean was
he would seem kinda like a useful idiot
to everyone else who was in real power
and that's that Mussolini wasn't very
good at it in compared it being evil in
comparison you know I mean I'm not
saying all of them are evil let's be
really really clear everybody okay
before hold your comments but Mussolini
kind of sucked at being evil well that
may be true I mean he certainly didn't
have the kind of scary you know didn't
have the power that Hitler didn't and he
recognized that but let's remember
Mussolini came to power in 1922 and he
was announced until 1943 history so he
he had a much longer tenure than Hitler
did Hitler will basically lasted a
little over a decade whistling he lasted
almost a quarter-century Hitler that
one-hit wonder the one-hit wonder that
Walther pp put an end to it otherwise he
would have been like ABBA
just churning out hits no that is true
and you know a good point to contrast
that doesn't mean that popular is right
you know Winston Churchill was ousted
immediately after wartime because people
wanted socialized health care that was a
big thing that people don't remember
about Winston Churchill so that that he
was there for a long time but yeah I
mean he just makes me sad cuz he's such
a wiener that's how I feel about
Mussolini sorry for the direction was
this let me ask what kind of pushback
have you gotten from the left with this
film considering not only the cover but
the theme you know going in with was
Lincoln and President Trump in the
Republican Party and their racist
Democrats well we've held back both on
the film and on the book the book comes
out July 31st the film is out August 3rd
no one's seen it and it is funny that
some people are attacking it without
having seen it but and in the past we've
done a lot of screenings and things so
people were able to see the movie before
it came out but we're open
one big bang and a thousand theaters
next week and I expect that things will
will get kind of lively at that point
now of course there's a professional
cadre of critics who tend to go see the
movie and then no matter what it says
they start bashing it yeah and this is
because they're on the left and
ironically the better the movie is the
more effectively makes the case the
lower these guys tend to rank it because
they realize that this is going to cause
them ideological pain so we pay no
attention to the critics what we pay
attention to is the audience and I
predict the audience that's gonna love
the film I do think they're gonna love
the film example of that actually was
did you ever watch the the miniseries
the Kennedys with Greg Kinnear I love
that was very very well it put its way
it is undeniably well done cuz a lot of
conservative stuff a lot of Christian
films out there not all that great we
all know that the the Kennedys was
really really good and it was actually
very accurate and that's why that's what
you liked it and it got panned by a lot
of critics final question we do have to
get going mr. de souza full pardon from
the United States president here with
the obviou basically undoing the
misdeeds of this previous administration
what does that feel like and can you now
buy a gun yes I can I feel like I got my
American Dream back and of course the
left was just rejoicing in the fact that
they could hang the felon label on me so
I'm now one of a very small population
steven of ex-felons does he normally if
you're a felon you're a felon called
like buddies there's a small population
of us pardon guys right now anyway I was
on CNN and they were like you know
Dinesh you really are the beneficiary of
preferential treatment very powerful
people like senator Cruz and the
president got you off and I'm like well
you know what some very powerful people
named Obama and holder and Preet Bharara
got me into this in the first place so
it took a few powerful people to get me
off they were too busy getting Chelsea
Manning a weiner yeah exactly exactly
Hori movie already oh yeah I know I
don't know exactly something with the
Manning and it involves a weiner but
that is I am I'm glad to hear it and
that would you're like The Count of
Monte Cristo most people go in and
they're imprisoned in the rep you
is tarnished for life but you were just
putting lines on the wall scratching it
through you made your way out and as
Edmond Dantes you put the other guy in
the back of the caravan and sent him to
prison then that's just the leftist
critics in the media you know they're
just gonna see the over this forever
Dinesh you enjoy that
well I'll feel that The Count of Monte
Cristo script is fully played out when
Obama or Hillary occupy my now vacated
bunk in the confinement center this is
waiting for yes there you go preferably
with a very angry inmate I I don't I
shouldn't say we don't mean that a
little bit all right the film is of
course death of a nation it premieres
August 3rd there's a book to go along
with it you can follow him at dinesh
d'souza the next D su D Souza just so
because sometimes like I can't find him
and they're doing di D Souza because
Nick DiPaolo confuse people mr. D'Souza
thank you so much we wish you best of
luck with the film always a pleasure
thank you
enjoy your freedom Nicole there it is
again so strong
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there handsome no not not you Oh
Lord no I'm talking about that snazzy
t-shirt looks like someone's been
dropping some coin at louder with grotto
shop calm now come near let the world
see don't be shy there we go that's what
I'm talking about oh no someone's trying
to be a sneaky fellow let's go we're
that bad boy loud and proud nothing to
be ashamed of here hey what's the big
idea
stop kidding around and show everybody
your swag don't make me come down there
well now your t-shirt just says
socialism which is far more embarrassing
there we go see nothing to be afraid of
available exclusively at louder with
Crowder shop calm mug clubbers are
almost never beaten up for wearing a
long-sleeve socialism is for [ __ ]
t-shirt unless of course your sickly
looking and lacking self-confidence and
that's why we now sell long-sleeve
versions perfect for those cool summer
nights and covering up a lifetime of Jim
avoidance and for decisions get yours
now with lardo with Grutter shop comm
that's louder with brighter shop comm
because anywhere else would be pure
[ __ ]
[Applause]
hey there one live read of the week not
only can you support of course the show
if you need a purchase firing by Walter
because of the wonderful sponsors of the
show but the show only continues to
exist because of Mudd Club ladder with
credit.com /mo Club we do the show full
hour every day and listen we're not
paying the bills with YouTube we've
talked about this and just so you know
as well they're about a dozen people
employed here a lot of work rather a lot
of people like you're seeing for the
first time Brautigan I've been with for
five years and they rely on Mudd Club
and they help contribute to the show so
a lot of people who aren't necessarily
on-air personalities they don't always
necessarily get the credit that they
deserve and if you don't like it you do
not have to join you can do free trial
99 dollars annually get this hand etched
mug as well as a lot of credit every
single day and all of the other
wonderful CR TV programming lotto with
Crider comm /mo and if you're student
veteran active military $69 okay do that
maybe buy a Walter if you need a gun
back to the show in that list of this
[Music]
I've never seen a garage I've never seen
a gorilla do this I've been waiting to
send me only with all the wrong I've
seen one inch and I've seen one head mmm
but I've never seen this the Premium
Package which is odd because the barrel
full of monk of the monkeys are doing
this it's predicated on the idea that
all monkeys do this lie I don't think
it's our next guest she's returning
guests the first time she came on it was
kind of a wild card we had no idea III
think she would say most the feedback
was very positive we really liked having
her on you can follow her on the Twitter
at Nicole Arbour of course you can also
check out her YouTube channel where she
receives hate regularly as well as
praise comedian extraordinaire to color
but how are you how are you I'm
fantastic good I'm glad to have you on
the show really nice and I'm so glad
that you haven't been fire bombed I've
been so worried about you guys thank you
very much well that was what inspired me
to bring you back you sent an email
after we did the the phone call with the
reporter at Austin Chronicle it seemed
like that was impactful for you for some
reason oh my gosh well just I've had so
much fake news written about me and I'm
just unlike the fake news warpath right
now yes and then watching you go in on
her baby so happy because I've also done
something similar with a reporter last
year after I did I hosted just like
lingerie fashion show and a man who
probably has never had sex in his life
decided that that was very offensive
called the girls strippers all sorts of
stuff and I called him on it live on my
Facebook in a second like there's a
litany of things just just kind of
thrown away first up he found a lingerie
fashion show offensive and so his insult
was stripper so it was raising funds for
like a children's charity kind of thing
it's like this guys night out
classy good rose were in lingerie but
whatever they did their best it was
small town in Canada but this reporter
you're making it sound like these women
have hugs like they don't they don't
have hubs but it wasn't the Victoria's
Secret Show production it was like the
the girls were all gorgeous everybody
did their best yes it was opportunity
okay but this gentleman I believe from
CBC comes in and writes this whole like
expose about the girls being escort
some strippers and like the strip show
and it's like that didn't happen and
then these poor girls were being like
fired from their jobs for being escorts
so I jumped in went on a phone call with
the dude but live streamed it on my
Facebook and I got him hey I didn't mean
the right review issues goggle search
google he asked her numbers so he could
validate his sources and when they
turned him down he wrote an article I
could by the way I can fact check this
zero but it sounds like it's probably
about right so I'm gonna trust also be
building to my live stream it was pretty
fun well I could appreciate that because
when I I had a lot of even some like
we've talked about this with the Young
Turks they actually used to go after me
and address me when I have like forty
thousand YouTube followers and now they
will roast every Tom Dick in here every
conservative not named steven crowder
because once once you crash anchors
panel as chanc Weger it kind of like
your name is the one that shall not be
spoken in their halls but that's
something to back then there used to be
fake news written and I had no ability
to really combat it you know if the
Daily Beast wrote something or of
Washington Post wrote something you kind
of had to take it on the chin and tell
your followers but they weren't numerous
back then and and that's what we thought
with the Austin Chronicle even though I
know they don't have a huge readership
it was just so inaccurate and so
emblematic of all the big newspapers
that's why we did it and she came to us
so it sounds like the same thing
happened to you it was so awesome I
loved it so much here for you guys thank
you just take a I think we having lead
or and he was one of the early YouTube
political channels how the world works
and really kind of nerdy super-smart
type and he has like a hundred fact
checks from Washington Post from
Washington Post fact checks where
they've labeled things accurate and he
has all the links and why they are
completely wrong and we'll do a full
hour show on fact-checking Washington
Post fact checks so well I'm glad that
you reached now I understand why it
resonated with you and we will do more
of that okay so you were this happened
this week Trevor Noah on the apology
tour for Aboriginal joke have you read
about this heard about this I have it no
tell me the story oh okay well you know
it's Trevor Noah is Trevor Noah and he
doesn't realize it appeasing crocodiles
is futile and and now apparently made a
joke about Aboriginal women he's a
stupid person he's a stupid person
really fun though and he has to jump in
that now and go apologize
I think it's fans we have Nepal he
refuses to apologize initially I don't
know the exact up-to-date right now at
the second of this interview but it was
a joke but he said you know for some of
you say you've never seen an attractive
it was actually a free funny joke so I
think the joke was this okay
and you can tell me if you find this
offensive or not and if he needs to
apologize as a woman as a woman as one
with breasts no man have breasts right
we should need to learn these things men
you get pregnant - I read at CNN his
joke was something along the lines of
you say that you've never met an
attractive Aboriginal woman and to you I
say yet something like that like you and
he said you haven't met all them and may
I I don't know some kind of sex joke and
apparently there's one deeply wounded
people now I don't like Trevor Noah
but I think it's a pretty benign joke I
also think that most Aboriginal women
are unattractive and my experience your
thoughts I have met a ton of really hot
Aboriginal women they're native Canadian
and Miss Canada last year is a freaking
babe actually I think she wouldn't miss
universe was talking about South African
cuz you have to say First Nations
so I I would never I would never refer
to them as Aboriginal so you're racist
and most have to scrub this time I've
been told I'm a racist many times it's
fine
I'm not even that fast but yeah I think
yes progressive and yeah be good go
ahead
I really appreciate you guys thank you
for helping with my hate yeah I just
think it's funny
whatever I just like that he has to
apologize now or that he's offended
people because he's he does it all the
time it's time for him to get well
because you also were telling me just
Rob off air that you were meeting with
the French soccer team with the World
Cup and you had a discussion about
Trevor Noah
so I met them okay this is a fun fun
thing so Trevor Noah was talking about
the French soccer team saying that it's
a win for Africa not for France and then
saying that they're all actually from
Africa and the team was like no two of
us were born in Africa but we're mostly
from here and France got really pissed
off their ambassador I think or someone
from the consulate wrote a letter to his
show they were pissed off about it and
Trevor's like no and he doubled down I
wrote a thing being like Trevor's just
mad because he's the whitest black guy
ever and he's just whatever he's four
and some she was funny yeah don't I get
an Instagram message from the French
soccer team laughing at my post I'm like
waiting for Nicole Arbour then I'm not
the Maxim Hot 100 party like a couple of
days ago and some little man in a suit
comes up to me and he looks magical and
I'm like I should follow him because he
said follow me well little man or a
little like actual like like a tall
human like I'm not talking about me
continue I just I just wanted to clarify
I wasn't trying to snide you but I'm
imagining this man he's just a tiny
gentleman he's not a little person per
se but he is a tiny man in this like
really nice suit and he's like follow me
someone wants to meet you I'm like oh my
god does he own a chocolate factory this
feels magical
so I follow him cuz that seems
reasonable and it was the French soccer
team and I have a video of them handing
me the world's Cup and I'm like wow like
we think it was funny like handing you
the World Cup for crapping on Trevor
Noah
exactly so I won this round I hate to
correct you but oppa lovers don't own
chocolate factories their internship
their indentured servitude adventured
servants to the chocolate thank you but
the man who does own the Chocolate
Factory wears very nice suits and he
could pretend that he walks weird and
then he does a front roll and it's
fantastic yeah good schlep was actually
you know it we actually had a little
person Jesus and little person Santa
Russell at our Christmas livestream for
the spirit of Christmas and pudding and
they were very spirited but I will taste
to this so I want to use I that's a good
example if they want if they say it
hurts my feeling to say [ __ ] or
whatever it is I understand but words
kind of matter and it's not really
descriptive when you say a little person
because we've said that for a long time
not meaning people who are now called
little people at one point it was
dwarves it could be a gymnast exactly it
could be a gymnast or david dowell being
escorted from a united flight
rightfully so it's really hard to tell
they're just little so that's the
problem that that's why this this ly no
Lenny Bruce and Tracy you've seen the
documentary probably write about him as
a comedian but they you know don't take
my
anyway I'm amazed at the left is coming
forwards and dictating this and do you
think that this is at last we spoke with
you you were kind of middle-of-the-road
it seems like you're do you think you're
leaning more more and more right now as
you've been embraced here's I am being
embraced and it feels nice
thank you to the people with brains I
appreciate you even if you just like me
because my shirt is low-cut I'll take it
um going in the back now go ahead oh I
know why I'm here Stephen so basically I
really love what I'm hearing on your
side but I think that I am the most
useful staying a little bit more purple
right now because when you're yelling at
people from either side the other side
doesn't listen to you that's probably
true but kind of my point is they yell
at you no matter what from the left
whether it's the fat-shaming issue which
we talked about this week what now you
see it with Trevor Noah I'm actually
surprised at the French soccer team went
out and grew grew grew spine a because
they're French and B because they're a
soccer team and were willing to step in
with you and making fun of Trevor Noah
the point I think everyone is so you've
gotta know I gotta tell you how funny it
was because I had to ask some the
questions so me asking these very ripped
black men so are you from Africa there
were just like no were French stupid
blonde idiot it was wonderful the
conversation the exchange everything it
was a lot of what did you say about
blacks in Canada now because I remember
I had a friend who was from Jamaica are
they staying yeah no I had a friend from
Draco who get really offended at African
American her name was her name was
Leanne and she'd say I have yes she was
like she's like I'm not out I have not
African my grandmothers are my
grandfather's grandfather growling she
went back many generations to Jamaica if
I had this roused today with people on
the interwebs because where do where
does it stop it's like I had a
conversation with someone they're like
I'm african-american I'm like oh so
you're from Africa they're like no I'm
from America I'm like but you've been to
Africa they're like no I'm like so
you're American they're like you're
racist I'm Monty Python this isn't real
life well no it is really cuz what
they're looking at you and then they're
bringing up a page from Hitler use and
they're going thought thought
so nailed it so it doesn't matter what
you say at that point I survived
everything ok this is an example do we
talk about earlier this week and then we
dipped it to get going um this this lady
saw who walked obviously there's a fat
pride thing is no new thing to you the
lady who walked the streets of New York
who was a size like 36 and then she got
mad that people were walking exactly
yeah just creating creating union jobs
to fix the potholes she's you know she's
boosting the economy's our shovel-ready
yes they're wheelbarrow ready jobs um
did you see this though where she got
mad about the fact that people were cat
calling her I didn't see that she should
be so happy well she got mad about it
yes exactly and here's kind of my point
I think this is something that later on
a lot of men right now and obviously I
said is because the fashion was kind of
your your rise to notoriety most women
are attractive to men like you talk
about those people in Canada lingerie
right I'm noticing a thief accident
party with midgets and lodge it seems
like there's a lot of lingerie going on
that's okay but the point is these women
aren't perfect like you said but men
find them attractive all the woman that
I know who are generally within the
boundaries of health most men would find
attractive we don't expand I think where
men get really upset about this and I
would wonder where you feel as a woman
who's been lambaste breaked over the
coals for talking on the same issue men
only expects women to look one way we
don't expect you to be one way we just
don't want to be demanded or compelled
to say that we have to love women every
single way we like women most ways just
not every single way it's the compel
it's the compulsion of finding something
attractive it is that kind of work I
totally get it
you make sense I don't like really
skinny guys because I feel like I'm
going to break them there's nothing
against really thin men I just I feel
like I will break you so I don't want to
play with you I don't find you sexually
attractive I don't want to pick my teeth
with a hit with I do you know what I
mean so I get it I get it in the reverse
and they can't force you to want to bang
them but here's the fun thing is guys
will pretty much bang anything and
they're always hotter than somebody
that's kind of the fun I made opposed to
go to that - it's like life's good
you're hotter than somebody but don't
force somebody to think you're hot
guys are like large black women they're
not gonna like me and I'm okay with that
right exactly that's that is exactly
correct and actually it's a little bit
harder for men well I don't realize I've
seen a lot of these articles we were
talking about this in the pitch meeting
where they say you know men if they're
fat they're just funny it's more
acceptable like one second but women
aren't sexually attracted to fat guys
that's not a regular thing like we're
the court jester
it's not yeah but it's the same problem
right and yeah I'm like fat women women
don't want to have sex with most fat
guys where's that guy one time I did I
did it was almost like my penance and it
makes you feel really attractive
honestly like he wasn't like the biggest
but he was bigger than I would usually
go for and it made me feel really hot so
girls do a fat guy at least once all
right I don't know if I'm comfortable
this direction what's the cutoff for
skinny for you what's the weight limit I
don't have a weight limit it's just like
a look if it looks like you care about
yourself and you don't smell weird I'm
okay okay all right well that's fine
well they're skinny guys who care about
themselves I'm sorry I took your show so
sexual I didn't mean it's okay I'm quite
certain you did final question you said
you you mentioned about the maxim party
with a lot of gold diggers there I would
imagine is very uncomfortable there were
a lot of gold diggers there and so many
girls were so upset by them but I I'm
not offended by gold diggers because
they're gonna have ugly kids like it's
not hot guys that have to buy women so
like karma is there [ __ ] don't worry
oh right okay if people want to follow a
YouTube channel and follow your tour
where do they go to call Instagram it's
the game please it's from I beat letter
I letter B Nicole Arbour on YouTube or
Facebook I'm Nicole Arbour Nicole Arbour
fans I'm pretty easy to find well no
it's not for Americans because you spell
it with a you just like Canadians spell
color so it's Nicole Arbour you are
we're very inclusive even with how many
letters can come play it this is true
and it put a little they put a little
skinny guy line through the seven all
right Nicole Arbour thank you so much we
have to go wrap this show up in a nice
boy I appreciate you taking the time
[Music]
hey kids I see that socialism is
starting to become a cool hip thing
because of that crazy eyed lady
Alexandria Cortez and of course Bernie
Sanders and his vape pens so I thought
I'd fill you in real quick about the
realities of socialism socialism is like
studying really really hard on a test
and you get in and then another kid gets
an F the teacher holds a gun to both of
your heads and now you both get C's
that's not very fair if you ask me so
when that crazy lady with her crazy eyes
talks about socialism she forgets to
mention that it always ends starvation
and genocide USSR ammonia cube
North Korea Venezuela Oh genocide to
Bernie Sanders has three houses and he
wants some more so he'll come to your
parents door and take your toys it's a
terrible terrible terrible idea
[Music]
for the riptides was a riptide of an
awesome show that's what that was dinesh
d'souza Nicole Arbour Cockburn Cuthbert
way to get rid of Brautigan before the
lesson he could not make it through
honestly I mean if you were bringing in
a deputee
I don't know how it works I don't know
what that really means I just knows how
it's pronounced over apparently when we
looked it up I've never even heard of
this term before wouldn't you for PR
purposes just not just fine anyone named
not I love it's also Kirsten Cockburn so
it's a double Kate's it's like a really
cheap well now the cats out of that we
avoided saying Kristen cut because all
the cop movies involved many were like
it's not as funny it's a woman it almost
seems like sexual it's almost seems Bill
O'Reilly asked if we talk about her as a
woman but we do we have an incredible
show with unbelievable shows lined up
free acts what you know who we have I
believe next week Lee Doran of how the
world works hasn't been around in a long
time he just sent us this article not an
article he sent us a sheet with like
eighty fact checks I think we just
talked about this with Nicole and I was
confirmed I believe for next week on
Washington Post they're fact-checking so
we're gonna do an entire episode on that
just to show you how far just to show
you how deep the roots are of dishonesty
in the median that's not to absolve
anyone on the right when they are
dishonest to the fake news that we
talked about on Facebook of course that
happens and I hate it when the right
does it but it has been a it's been a
long-standing history at the left yep
going complete is their full-time job
they they consider that that it's their
privilege in life can you name me check
with their own facts can you name me any
liberal journalists who remain who was
unbiased who just delivered the news
Brian Williams no dan Rather no Don
Lemon no Gary Cooper no because at one
point Walter Cronkite of course not no
at one point they were all considered
journalists you expect the Lauryn Hill
Donald's madhouse
none of them I can't say the probably
the closest would be Shep Smith and he's
like a moderate Democrat as far as I
understand it no but none of them not
one think about that for a second name
me one of you okay Jake Tapper I
remember when I when I start mm I was at
PJTV and hot air and Ed Morsi they were
talking but you know what Jake Tapper
tends to be pretty good there you go
about now it's just just every time even
like just like two years ago I used to
think Jake Tapper was much more down the
middle honest I thought that too
and then then they always veer it's a
curveball at the end starts having a
couple of brunches with Chris Cuomo and
now you end up with this no all right so
let me kind of tell you something here I
uh
we usually get into this last segment I
think now KJ was one who said that we
should name this segment something
because sometimes we were like I wish I
could upload this we should just like
have a name for like uh well the crowd
or something with Courtney maybe writing
because we're working to change my mind
book and we're trying to make it very
economical maybe doing a pamphlet
version of people who are in college
just the really basic arguments and then
maybe doing a longer hard cover for
people who want to buy it as a gift but
there's another book that I've been
thinking about for a while the self-help
book you'll hate and a couple of things
I've talked about really very
consistently there aren't a lot of key
details you need to know in life to
avoid the major pitfalls as far as being
successful and having interviewed the
most successful people in any of their
meals with us Daniel Cormier whether
it's Brian Shaw with its people like
Thomas soul something consistent you
have to believe in yourself
realistic belief in yourself and
consistency and discipline that's the
good stuff
but today let me get to two really
really bad things the worst things for
the human soul I'll start with myself I
lied to my mom recently really bad
bold-faced lie you know what it was
sorry mom turns out she needs bunion
surgery you know this mhm and I actually
I did the same when my dad had melanoma
and I just said like skin cancer that's
the easiest thing to remove now that's
true but not melanoma my mom I don't
know a whole lot about bunion surgery
okay all I know is that I've heard it's
terrible and my dad reiterated that
saying if you have to do two bunion
surgeries they say do it all cuz you'll
never go back so my mom said I have to
get bunion surgery without even thinking
I said oh that's an easy one turned
around and it's it's it's wrong okay
what I did was wrong it was a cowardly
act it was a it's a cowardly way of
dealing with the pain of the issue and
trying to mitigate it that's the reality
of it I know people think white lies and
yeah there is a difference in severity
of lies and we'll get into that but it
still is cowardly because I was sitting
there going I don't want to deal with
this right now
oh you'll be fine melanoma bad no big
thing truth is I should have dealt with
it head-on and been honest about it now
some of you out there before I get into
some of this advice some of you are
beyond tell
let me explain what I mean by this if
you can take all the advice in the world
you can apply it and you'll still be
miserable we've seen it how well do we
know who read the books they put up the
affirmations they have their prayer
groups they do all the things that
they're supposed to do and how all to me
but they just never ever get their crap
together and and they're beyond helping
and by that I mean you helping someone
or me helping but these people are not
beyond hope they're beyond physical help
from people like you or I not hope let
me explain what I mean by that I had an
aunt uh Nicole she's just passed away
recently lung cancer
socialized health care I'll get into
then a whole other time but she was Iowa
was always always afraid of her she was
kind of mean she was very mean actually
as a kid I just died the last person I
wanted to say was with my aunt Nicole I
didn't know this growing up but she had
a very abusive childhood not from my
grandparents but they couldn't afford to
to raise her during the Great Depression
so she had to go live with another
family for a period of time while they
got on their feet and they were horrible
to her so it makes sense now but when I
was growing up my Aunt Nicole scared me
I thought she was very very
mean-spirited and I didn't like her I
didn't like being around her I was
scared of her she never forgave my
grandmother okay when my grandmother was
dying from lung cancer and they prayed
together and my grandmother apologized
and she forgave her I know some people
say people never change there's some I
saw now this person would be beyond help
because my entire life that I knew her
she was never a nice person and then
after this death after this forgiveness
she was the nice aunt she was the person
whose apartment I wanted it was an
entire I've never seen anything like it
it was like Ebenezer Scrooge only it
would have been considered lazy writing
so I've seen it okay so some people are
beyond help but they're not beyond hope
it just means that yet listen is it as a
Christian I could I can call it
spiritual healing you call it whatever
you want maybe something happened with
their neurotransmission I have no idea
was like a whole different aunt Nicole
go back to my lie it's wrong it's not
altruistic almost all eyes pretty much
all of them span from cowardice and the
two things most corrosive to the human
soul while we talk about the things that
lend themselves to success are on eclis
success also that can really destroy
people an aspect of life with external
factors not entirely in your control
I've talked about this now there are
factors at play and cowardice we've
talked about this which is internal
over which you have complete control and
the worst sin that you can commit
against anyone more importantly yourself
is a lies of cowardice and yet live to
avoid hurting someone's feelings like I
did those ultimately spawn from
cowardice I was afraid to deal with hurt
feelings and so I sidestep little why
sometimes I justify it but it wasn't
right but as far as the lies that that
really mold your soul it's the cowardly
lines that you tell to save yourself and
I've done that all eyes are told to
avoid discomfort that's the reality
right the difference really clocks in
between telling a lie to avoid someone
else's discomfort like what someone
asked if they look fat versus telling a
lie to avoid discomfort yourself often
knowing that that burden that hurt gets
passed on to someone else and I've done
that too there was a period of my life
when I was in junior high where I've
done that too or like lying to a friend
we need to pick him up at to the airport
you say you're unavailable really you're
doing nothing you're playing video games
all of us have done that that's the less
of your version but you're not lying to
not hurt his feelings you're lying
because you want to pick up the airport
okay lying about the broken vase etre
mom merely liked I did that saying it
wasn't you I wasn't lying to save my mom
I was lying to save myself are they you
go to more extreme examples Jesus thirty
pieces of silver what about lying to
someone what about telling someone you
love them giver done that you ever tell
someone you love them and you don't
other than that or tongues I'm gonna
trust you that's something we say a lot
right all the time how do we really know
what trust means this is why I said
because need to be able to trust
yourself this is the actual definition
of trust it's the firm belief in the
reliability truth ability or strength of
someone or something I've really tried
to curb using that word because we say
it all the time trust me trust me trust
me is a promise costumes yeah trust me
they have the Canadians they're gonna go
all the way this year what one second
that's a lie
there's no way you could ensure that
trust there's no way you could ensure
that the Montreal Canadiens are going to
win the Stanley Cup this year why should
I trust you
why just just say I hope they do trust
me I know how to fix a car when you've
never worked on a car I did that once
when someone said you know how to fix a
starter I said yes no clue it was my own
car to be fair was my own dachshund and
I ruined it turns out it was a it was a
transistor alternator or something
anyway but
or trust me I got your back we know that
well as a colloquialism but we usually
don't mean it right just like I uh trust
me man I gotta be real I got you
trust me lies of cowardice breed
betrayal and of those who trust us most
those who love us most of ourselves we
betray yourself and we all want hair
lino this to be true this is one thing
it's really uncomfortable for people to
talk about because uncomfortable to
admit it yourself like I've had to do
but human beings we don't have a lot of
respect for this kind of stuff like
Longshanks is gonna Longshanks no one
really thinks a brave heart and faults
Longshanks it's a man who betrays brave
heart out of cowardice who you can't
stand bein memorable you can kind
understand it you don't blame him for
being a rival you just have no respect
for Catwoman for locking him in the
little guy who's Mickey steps that and
that that Australian actor I always
forget his name but I like him he was in
bloodline he thought the money would
save him from his own cowardice how
often do people insult cowards for
example by calling them Pontius Pilate
never its Judas and that's what we use
when we often call people out and that
stems from lies was carries and there's
a real practical reason why decent
people revolted by that kind of
cowardice and this is the Sun this is
the one thing again with success
handling success it's a whole other deal
we've watched people deal with success
both really well and really poorly
people who've been on this show some of
them it can hurt everyone around you but
give you a practical reason in combat
sports okay the first thing they teach
you one of the first thing they train is
how to channel the flinch reflex right
they teach you in boxing for example not
to look away so sure you learn your
footwork you learn your head movement
you learn how to avoid taking a hit on
the button but you also learned that
this is a fight and every now and then
one shot is going to slip through none
of us are getting out of this life alive
and no one is getting out unscathed at
least a few shots are coming through and
when they do you cannot look away and
turtle that's the first thing you're
taught because you're just dead at that
point you haven't hit the ground because
the coward the person who lies to
themselves a person who lies to others
out of cowardice thinks they're avoiding
the discomfort but you're just setting
yourself up for the next shot and that's
what happens to people who live their
entire life that way when truth is
coming down the pike you turtle up to
avoid the discomfort and then guess what
there's more truth come all right into
it
and I've done it I've had times our life
trip and they're trying to avoid the
discomfort with lies of cowardice and
you know what happens when you turtle up
and you look away you don't see the next
shot coming you never see what's coming
down the pipe you're afraid to deal with
a discomfort and you set yourself up for
a world of hurt and it sucks your soul
out of your body and I've seen people
who are on the twilight years of their
life who live their entire life that way
and you just get March stepped into the
corner and taken out some of you are
beyond help but not beyond hope some of
you have been telling these lies of
cowardice for so long that they become
second nature there's nothing I could
say or anyone anything you could say for
thinking of someone your life that would
be able to they'd even be able to
acknowledge it but most of you the vast
majority of you watching this you can
catch it the very next time you're put
in the hot seat you have a chance to
tell a lie that even you know people
will believe and get you out of it
that's the test not do you lie when do
you stop lying when you know you get
caught do you decide not to lie when you
know you can get away with it tell the
truth instead
that's bravery it's not only doing the
right thing in the face of fear but
doing the right thing when present
that's the thing with brave we've often
heard fearless you've heard me say this
before they're fearless brave people
aren't fearless they're fearless people
are psychopaths people who are afraid
they're psychopaths brave people do
what's right in the face of fear more
importantly bravery is doing the right
thing not only in the face of fear but
when presented with the equally
available option of comfort through a
lie whether there's the brave and
there's the feel from know there's not
the brave and the fearful the brave are
fearful the world is filled with the
brave the cowards it is filled with the
leaders the strong men women heroes the
people we admire and the comfortable and
it's a lot easier to stop those lies of
cowardice now tomorrow so here's what
you do people say all right what's
here's a life tip some of you're beyond
help but wake up tomorrow and say okay I
will make it a point Jordan Pearson
talks about this to never tell a lie
to just just to get myself out of a body
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna allow
myself to do it you know I'm not gonna
lie Perry just tell the truth
you don't even have to always tell the
truth just don't tell the lie iio after
the Bunyan thing I spoke with my mom
I'm sorry mom this is really gonna hurt
and it was very very uncomfortable you
know what it was the right thing to do
and then because we're being honest I
can be there for as she needs me to be
so that's it the two things that we've
talked about with interviewing the best
people in the world believing in
yourself discipline consistency two
things that destroy success and
cowardice and cowardice always breeds
lying to avoid discomfort that's what
most of us as human beings we avoid
discomfort leave the hard door open as I
always say do it tomorrow
you can do it it's an easy step it's a
self-help book you're gonna hate you
won't like it see you next week
[Music]
you